اتمنى فيها الاستوديو زميلتنا من غرفه
الاخبار رمضان عويطيه اهلا بك رمضان
مؤتمر صحفي للاحتفال ب 60 عاما على
التوقيع الاتفاقيه المصالحه بين البلدين
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه نقاط خلافيه
كثيره بين المانيا
وفرنسا بالاحرى بين الشمس وماكرون
والمؤتمر الصحفي هذا اظهر ان هذه النقاط
لحتى الان لم يتوصل الزعيمان الى ايجادي
همم ارضيه مشتركه بينهما
الارضيه المشتركه حتى الان التي وضعها
الرئيسان او الرئيس ماكخون والمستشار
الالماني هي الحرص على البناء الاوروبي
لان البناء الاوروبي معناها المصالح
الاستراتيجيه لكل من فرنسا ولالمانيا نقاط
التوافق كانت المناخ الاستثمار في الشباب
الاستثمار في الطاقات النظيفه اا دعم
اوكرانيا ولكن هذا الدعم مختلف راينا بان
الرئيس ماكرون كان همم يعني همم فضفاضا
همم تم الحديث في مؤخرا ان فرنسا يمكن ان
ترسل دبابات همم من همم يعني مدرعات الى
همم الى اوكرانيا لتعطيه هذه الديناميه
الجديده راينا هنا الاجابه بالنسبه لرئيس
بان همم اوكرانيا لن تحيد قيد المولى عن
عقيدتها عقيدتها هي انها لن تساهم في
تاجيش هذا الصراع وهذا ما قاله ايضا
الرئيس ماكرون من خلال القول بانه لا يسعى
الى تصعيد الان
نعرف بان الدول اوروبا الشرقيه همم يعني
همم
قدمت الكثير من الانتقاد لفرنسا والمانيا
لانهما حارصتان على الحديث مع ايضا مع همم
بوتين وهذا ما قاله همم شورت ولكنه قال
بانه همم متمسكا بوحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه
فبالتالي لا تنازل استراتيجي ولكن ايضا لا
تستعيد من ناحيه الدخول في الحرب كشريك
وقال شو اسمه نريد ان ندعم السلام لاننا
عرفنا السلام ويجب المحافظه عنه عليه
النقطه الثانيه الهامه جدا بالنسبه للطاقه
هناك تنازل فرنسي حول اشتراك المانيا في
خط الطاقه الهيدروجينيه اللي كان من
المقرر بين اسبانيا والبرتغال وفرنسا
الرئيس
المانيا توزيعها لكن توسيع هذا الحلف الى
المانيا بالمقابل شولت قال بانه همم بان
ظروف همم الجيو الاستراتيجيه والسياسيه
والجغرافيه لا تستطيعوا من خلاله لا
يستطيع ان يدرج لا بولندا ولا فرنسا في
اطار الدرع الجوي مع همم 14 دوله في حلف
الناته والولايات المتحده
الخلاف مع فرنسا 4 10 دوله
تنازل من ناحيه مد اربعه في خطوط
الهيدروجين واشرك المانيا قال سنرى كيف
يمكن ان نجد حلولا مستقبليه وهو فتح
معناها هذه النقطه الخلفيه وهذه النقطه
المفاوضات همم كما ان هناك ايضا يعني لم
تتم الحديث ولا كلمه واحده عن النقطه
الخلافيه الكبرى الاخرى وهي الطاقه
النوويه فرنسا ااه يعني تعول على طاقه
النوويه كطاقه استراتيجيه في السنوات
المقبله شولس يقول همم
سنعمل على تطوير منصه اا الطاقه في الشمال
وسنشرك همم فرنسا اذا همم دون الحديث عن
خوض في الطاقه النوويه وهو امر طويت صفحته
في المانيا هناك همم هناك شعور بان
المانيا تريد ان تخرج همم ويعني تلعب على
همم يعني تحفظ الفرنسي من الولايات
المتحده
والاستقلاليه الاقتصاديه لتبرز دورا لها
في اوروبا هذا جديد وهذا فرنسا لا تقبل به
يعني بطريقه او باخرى المانيا
في القمه في القمه الاوروبيه الاخيره قال
نعم قال بان المانيا يجب ان تعزل نفسها عن
بقيه الشركاء همم الزواج صحه تعبير
الالماني الفرنسيه وهما محكومان محكوم هذا
الزواج باستمرار هناك خلافات كثيره هناك
طرف ثالث دخل على هذا الزواج وهو الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه معناه مشاكل لكن هذا
الزواج لن يحدث لن يذهب الى طلاق لان
الطلاق ليس في مصلحتنا فرنسا ولا المانيا
الازمات الاخيره راينا بانها
جعلت القوى الاوروبيه اجبرت القوى
الاوروبيه على التحرك معا ازمه كونفيد
العام 2020 راينا كيف المانيا اغلقت
حدودها ولم تمت فرنسا بال همم الكمامات
ولكنها تراجعت عن هذا واضطرت الدول
الاوروبيه في ظل الازمات الى التقدم حتى
وان اختلفت المصالح